if I think we roll the executive
director of the International Energy
Agency on the consequences on EU energy
policy one year after Russia's Invasion
and War of aggression against the
Ukraine I would like to welcome the two
distinguished guests and of course with
this it is important to look what was
achieved and how we took the necessary
measures and very good measures in order
to
counter-attack the actions direct
actions of Russia and of course the
indirect consequences of the aggression
against Ukraine but also
to look in the future because
unfortunately the war is not over yet
some will fear of some excalibation and
it's important in this context we need
to respond with urgency to the several
challenges still in terms of security of
Supply
maybe the high energy prices
infrastructure bottlenecks bottlenecks
and of course to look to the
geopolitical context which was changed a
lot and what we expect in the coming
months and maybe years in the field of
energy policy that's why I'm really
grateful to commissioner Simpson and
executive director Bureau for having
accepted our invitation to frame this
discussion giving their insight and the
extraordinary expertise and of course
have this exchange of views with us
we uh have uh first the introductory
remarks of the two guests then the first
round of political group coordinators or
Representatives then the replies the
feedback from them and then the second
round we have already a number of
speakers so please colleagues uh respect
the time
immediately after this will have also a
press conference I will have a press
conference together with a commissioner
and executive director by saying that I
go directly to commissioner caddy
Simpson for her introductory remarks
please and thank you once again for
being here
good morning
and I'm grateful for Christian and it's
a committee for organizing this debate
um to Mark the one year anniversary of
the repower EU strategy it is very
timely the Russian boring and stew crane
has caused a tremendous shift in
Europe's Energy System in one year
the transformation triggered by the war
and by repower you has been
unprecedented in a moment I will talk
about how far we have come and
delivering three power UI agenda and
about what lies ahead but first I want
to look at what this dramatic air has
meant for Ukraine and its NH System 12
months ago Ukraine was the main gas
transit route towards the European Union
40 PCM a year based on the trilateral
agreement concluded in 2019 it had a
large power sector synchronizes Russian
and the private system even if plans for
synchronization with the European greed
bear in the making Ukraine hosted four
nuclear power plants including the
largest in Europe and was committed to
work on improving safety with the help
of the Union it was reforming and
modernizingly Regulatory framework so
fast forward one year since October
Ukraine's power sector has been under
constant Russian missile and drone
attacks the latest took place this night
ukrainians have endured constant
sacrifices Europe's largest nuclear
power station in subrosia is occupied by
military forces in violation of all
International conventions with great
risks for nuclear incidents
the technicians engineers and nuclear
experts
are risking their lives every day and
this very moment to prepare and replace
damaged infrastructure disruption on
this scale could have brought any Energy
System into sneeze but Ukraine has not
given up it has resisted its Invasion
and Europe has stood by Ukraine every
step of the way
we were able to synchronize or
synchronize the Ukrainian and moldovan
electricity Network in the pace of three
weeks instead of two years
previously planned and we introduced a
strong set of sanctions against Russia
including the oil and coal
we delivered 1 600 generators and
thousand four hundred Transformers to
Ukraine and I set up a dedicated fund
with the energy Community which today
totals 180 million euros in places
as we go forward we will continue to
support Ukraine currently we are working
to promote decentralized production of
electricity with off-grid solar panels
and last Friday I welcome to offer by NL
to provide Ukraine
panels produced in Europe and this is
just the beginning and I invite all
member states and companies to join this
initiative and scale up
and I'm also working with sensory to
make sure that the electricity trade
volumes can be progressively increased
for both imports and exports
we have integrated Ukraine in the gas
joint purchasing platform with a view to
help secure two billion cubic meters of
additional gas and we are working on
Market reforms in the context of the
accession process and I continue
engaging with the iaea to insist that
occupation of support nuclear power
plant is a crime
and a danger doll and every effort
should be made to create secure Souls
honorable members of the European
Parliament I wanted to start my remarks
with Ukraine because this is not a Side
Story it's at the heart of our empowered
actions the invasion of Ukraine was
preceded by a manipulation by Russia of
our gas markets to destabilize the union
and to create uncertainty that supplies
have been used to leverage blackmail and
divide member states to weaken the
resolve to pose nine just and illegal
war and such actions made it crystal
clear that the union should put an end
by Massive dependency we had a Russia
built over decades and this is exactly
what we have set out to do with the
power EU agenda many doubted that
was it even possible but one year on the
shift
uh in the European Energy System is
spectacular let's take a gas
diversification as an example since
September 2022
Russian gas is about eight percent of
all pipeline gas imported to EU pipeline
gas imports from Russia amounted 61
billion cubic meters last year the first
gas supplier to Europe is no longer
Russia it is Norway
some doubted that Europe would ever be
able to receive the LNG
that was needed to replace Russian gas
due to the limitations in the physical
capacity of LNG terminals but facts tell
a different story in less than one year
three new terminals were open and five
more will be open by the end of this
year for a total capacity of 50 PCM and
in 2022 we received in total 135 billion
cubic meters of LNG from the global
market
for from the United States for instance
instance we received 56.4 this is 34
billion cubic meters more than in
previous years
the increase of cash applies from other
sources and Russia was almost 10 percent
higher than they estimated in the March
republication and overall the new phased
out Russian gas by two-thirds
we packed up this diversification effort
these new tools we have introduced a
common storage policy in three months
thanks to the work of this committee and
it's about
professor buzak
and this has worked well we filled
storage up to 95 by November last year
and it's still around 57 percent this is
more than twice the level of our
underground car storage last year and we
have introduced a framework for recorded
casting ontroduction all member states
committed to reduce their consumption by
at least 15 percent and they did so
demand dropped by more than 19
percent between August and January and
this helped us to save 42 billion cubic
meters of gas
we have set up an NIH platform to
support diversification and join
purchasing and we have introduced a
mechanism to correct price peaks in the
DTF gas market not justified by the
fundamentals of global markets and we
will propose to extend MCM to all other
hubs and we did all that without
derailing the green tea
last year carbon emissions dropped in
Europe by two and a half percent
an important part of your power EU was
to boost Renewables deployment to
replace gas in power generation and
heating and this has matched
expectations and possibly exceeded them
last year we generated more electricity
from wind and solar than from gas
so 2022 was a record here for solar
energy in the EU with 41 gigabytes of
new capacity installed and wind
capacitors Rose
by 15 gigahertz so last year 39 of our
electricity came from Renewables and
this wide-ranging change happened not
just because top down instructions from
governments it was a Grassroots movement
with Europeans leading the change they
have installed millions of solar PVS on
the roofs they are putting heat pumps in
their homes and they have adjusted their
Lifestyles
um this was sadly driven by high energy
prices but not only everyone has played
their part
that is where we stand today but the
value of our discussion is not in
looking back it lies in looking forward
to the next steps
so let me conclude by making three
remarks on the future
first on the outlook for the next
heating season we are in a good position
when this winter without any shortage
and to start the next refilling season
with confidence and half full storage
will explain in a moment so we should be
under No Illusion that things are
getting easy this year will be
challenging and the year after that as
well many uncertainties remain and we
need to keep a healthy and prudent
Supply
demand balance
I am going to propose to member states
to prolong the voluntary demand
reduction by 15 until next year
this has worked well and it's best
guarantee to achieve another great level
of storage by November we will continue
and extend our efforts at
diversification around the world and to
ensure reliable supplies to Europe
second we received last year around 20
billion cubic meters of Russian LNG
I think that we can and should get rid
of Russian energy completely as soon as
possible still keeping in mind our
security of supply and I encourage all
member states and all companies to stop
buying Russian LNG and not to sign any
new gas contracts as Russia once the
existing contracts had expired
committing not to renew existing
contracts as Russia
is the best way to give a long-term
Assurance to our reliable partners that
meaningful demand will stay
third in my view Europe will win this
energy War when we finally deliver on
our renewable energy objectives for me
the end goal of Republic is not to
replace one unreliable source of gas
with another trusted source of natural
gas it is to leverage Europe's energy
independence by massively increasing
Renewables we need to accelerate our
installation rate
and to that tent we need to take five
steps this year first the dialogue on
the red three must be finalized as soon
as possible I welcome the progress that
we have had so far but we need an
agreement on ambitious targets and a
robust enabling framework by the end of
March second we need to use all the
potential in particular on biomethane
and heat pumps but I will launch a
practical initiative to promote
biomethane
by the end of this year and
um
you can also expect from from our side
that
um we will
present a strategy on heat pumps
and third we need to accelerate the
construction of large-scale offshore
projects we have two Summits this year
one in all standard another in Lithuania
and we will need to make progress fourth
there is a need to look at Creed
developments to remove a serious
bottleneck and I'm advocating to include
Creed Manufacturing in our net sale
industrial act that will be presented
next week and finally I will prioritize
incentivizing Renewables in the reform
of the electricity Market design we need
a reform that will help bring down
prices and protect consumers but also
that strengthen in incentives for new
investments in Renewables
honorable members one year ago many
would have said that ending our
dependency from Russia is Mission
Impossible and look at where we are now
this is thanks to our unity and also the
work of this committee
let me thank in particular you
chairperson
um you have been a great interlocutor
even when we had these difficult choices
with article 122 proposals
and we have come a long way but we still
have a tough job ahead of us
so um
I offer all my
cooperation to you but
only together we will be able to deliver
the necessary missing pieces in our
legislation this year thank you
thank you thank you so much dear
commissioner thank you for all your
involvement congratulations for
everything it was achieved thank you for
coming uh so often Twitter committee to
discuss to take the input from our
colleagues the good ideas that
contributed also to the decisions that
were taken and of course thank you to
hold the whole team from dgnr and
everyone uh the two coordinated for the
good dialogue during this year of Crisis
and of course we are looking forward to
work very closely together in the future
we have a very
important privilege to have here with us
today the executive director of the
International Energy agency Dr fatik
birol uh extremely knowledgeable with a
very strong voice during this year of
crisis of War but not only of course
even before uh with the most important
challenges that the International Energy
sector but also European energy sector
faced and with a lot of very interesting
solutions that I'm looking on the
website of International
Energy agency Please Mr Bill you have
the floor now
uh thank you very much Mr chairman Mr
busek Madam commissioner dear members of
the parliament is a great privilege for
the International Energy agency to share
our views about the European
energy station of today and also
tomorrow
dear colleagues 24th of February was a
major milestone in the history of energy
not only for Europe but for the entire
world
because
Russia the country that invaded Ukraine
is not any country when it comes to
energy
as of 24th of February
Russia was the number one
energy exporter of the world
number one in oil
top oil exporter number of other Natural
Gas
major player in the coal markets
in electricity markets and Beyond
so therefore it triggered the first
Global energy crashes with implications
for everybody
in the world
but of course Europe was at the
epicenter of this crisis
so today in the next few minutes uh the
colleagues I would like to talk under
three headlines one
is a congratulations
second is a warning
and third is an indicating an
opportunity for Europe
first
now many people thought
is of 24th of February and there was a
lot of visual thinking from Kremlin and
as far that the Europe as a result of
resisting
against Russia together with Ukraine and
the International Community would mean
in court Europe would freeze
and Europe would have major economic
damage
but European countries
and the commission moved in solidarity
in a pragmatic way
and took very urgent and right decisions
and International Energy agency
only one week after the invasion on
first of March came up with a 10 point
plan which we have suggested to European
governments
and today I would like to show you why I
think it is time after one year to
congratulate European union and the
institutions
we are a number driven organization
we make our hands dirty with data every
day
so just with the numbers I want to show
you why it is time today after one year
to congratulate Europe and European
institutions
number one
we have seen that the in one year of
time Russian oil and gas revenues
a major input for the Russian budget
declined by a major 40 percent
this is in my view a major help to
ukrainians and ukrainians defense
and our analysis show that dick decline
will only deepen in the next months to
come
the second indicator
the share of Russian gas in Europe
in a very short period of time one year
is very short for the energy sector in a
very short period of time decline
substantially
another good indicator
Renewables
a huge increase in renewable energies
mainly driven by solar but also wind and
others huge increase about 40 percent
this is driven by also
by the fact that many countries see
renewable energies not only a solution
to our climate problems but also a
solution to our energy security problems
energy security was a key driver of the
big renewable growth
heat pumps again a big crops
Poland is the leader but in Finland in
rest of Europe we have seen huge growth
in heat pumps to reduce the gas
consumption
we work very closely with the
manufacturers of heat pumps around the
world
in Europe they were always complaining
in the past that they don't have enough
work to do now they are still
complaining because they are not able to
meet the demand coming from their
customers
electric cars
also a big cloth
so all clean energy
options increase while the gas decreased
and many people taught and said Europe
has double standards
Europe tells the world that the we have
to reduce the emissions and Europe is
using a lot of coal therefore European
emissions will go up where is the
European instructions European views
and these views are driven to be wrong
as well
because our numbers show that the
European emissions decline is a
significant 2.5 percent
so dear colleagues last year
in the middle of the first Global energy
crisis European epicenter we have seen
that the all the efforts from Europe and
its Partners we were able to see Russian
oil and gas revenues decline
the share of Russian energy in Europe
decline
cleared and add your options increase
and the emissions decrease and we have
not seen a major blackout or heating
problems
we did have some bruises economic and
social bruises that's for sure but this
is far less worse than it was taught
before so therefore my first point is
congratulations to Europe and European
institutions include the commission and
Madam commissioner here
is a warning as I mentioned to you
yes we are as it seems we are off the
hook if I may say so this winter
but another winter is coming the next
winter
and there are three factors
that are with us now and that may not be
with us next winter so therefore I see
in some government leaders when I talk
with them a bit of a overconfidence
about the current
achievements now and therefore is my
warning my warning is next winter may be
more difficult
then this winter for three reasons
number one
this winter we were lucky to import a
lot of LNG from the markets to replace
the Russian Pipeline gas
and one of the reasons that we were able
to import a lot of LNG is
China
which is the top LNG importer of the
world Chinese economy was met
Chinese domestic gas consumption decline
for the first time in the year 2022
since 40 years
therefore Chinese LNG Imports decline
significantly therefore there were a lot
of LNG in the markets and we could go
and buy this LNG
but now
all the indications show that the
Chinese economy is rebounding
therefore China's LNG import needs will
be increasing therefore China is coming
to LNG markets is a major strong buyer
with strong financial muscles this is
the first reason of the warning
second reason
every year certain amount of LNG
projects finish and they come to the
market
available for the buyers
this year
2023 the amount of new LNG
capacity coming to Global markets is one
of the lowest in the history
only slightly higher than 20 BCM which
is very very low
therefore the pool of LNG
is rather small for Europe to uh to buy
it this is the second reason
why the warning third
we have to be honest with ourselves we
have to be realistic here that one of
the factors helped us
this year
to
go through without major problems is
that we had a relatively in fact more
than relatively a mild winter
nobody can guarantee that next winter
will be as much as this winter and if it
is in line with to use your temperatures
then this may be a problem
therefore
it is my warning here we shouldn't be
too relaxed too overconfident we should
be happy with our achievement our
solidarity our Unity our pragmatic
policies but get ready for the next
winter which intense energy agency is
again working with the member countries
providing guidance and suggestions to
them this is my second point
and now my third and last point
it is about the European
in September
last year
I wrote the opet by saying that the
Europe needs to have a new industrial
master plan
because there are two major pressure
points
number one
Europe
industry is based on a model
which is
getting the later abundant and cheap
Russian energy
this is finished
there is no going back
European energy in the future will be
more expensive than
this will put a lot of pressure and the
competitiveness of the European
Industries energy the big part of the
production cost of Steel aluminum cars
whatever you chemicals whatever you
produce
there's you
from a the disadvantages position
we read
that the current European energy process
came down compared to 24th of February
crisis this is true and it's a good news
but dear colleagues
even Today's Energy prices in Europe
are three times higher than the
historical averages of Europe
Three Times Higher
European natural gas prices today
which people say came down which they
did which is right is seven times more
expensive than in the United States
so U.S natural gas is seven times
cheaper than a European natural gas
prices
she came down
yes but they are still three times more
expensive than the Chinese electric
suppressors
so therefore we have a fact here
and this will not change broadly
in the future Europe energy process will
be higher than previous European energy
process
and higher significant
and it is economic competitors
therefore European industry policy needs
to change this is the reason number one
why there is a neat new European
industry master plan
We Are The World Is entering
a new Industrial Age
the age of clean energy technology
Manufacturing
it is the batteries it is the electric
cars solar panels windmills
smrs and all of them
and who is going to produce this
currently there is one country
is making a major major inroads it is
China
when I look there you look at this chart
you see that China is currently
dominating the game for example
batteries which is the main component of
clean energy in many reasons 75 percent
of the batteries delivered is today
manufactured
and the United States came up with the
inflation reduction act to be a part of
the new Industrial Age clean energy
technology manufacturing and our numbers
show that even Euro Ira the inflation
reduction Act is fully successful
goes seamless the 75 percent of the
share of batteries the the China's share
of batteries in the world will go down
only to 55 percent
and what about Europe
and I think Europe needs to be also the
part of clean energy uh technology
manufacturing and it is the second
reason I believe Europe needs to analyze
in the entire supply chain
of clean energy
where Europe can have a Competitive Edge
and what kind of financial economic
and also energy policies need to be put
in place otherwise Europe industry will
be first producing
not competitive products
produce obsolete products
and it is the reason why we need to see
a new European industry a master plan in
liability new cost of energy realities
and in line with the next chapter of
Industrial Age
if not and I'm finishing here I believe
European economy
will get a big hit
and as the industrial sector
is a major backbone of the European
employment
VVC significant employment and social uh
pressures and a weak European economy
and being less competitive in the
industrial sector would mean the
Europe's status in the international
Affairs will be diminished
so these are the three points I wanted
to bring to attention the first ever
congratulations of the last year
performance and heads up for the next
winter and every chapter longer term the
industrial competitiveness and
opportunity Mr chairman thank you very
much for your time
thank you thank you very much thank you
for uh reminding us some important
realities for uh uh telling very clearly
what many of us are thinking that uh the
bad days are not over yet I hope but
could we should prepare maybe for some
difficult situation um during next
winter and you you gave the main reasons
and also okay of course uh looking to
the industrial competitiveness of our
industry an issue very dear to the heart
of many colleagues in the committee I go
now to the first round uh please uh dear
colleagues and please also dear guests
to respect now the times because we have
a press conference at 12 15 and the
journalists generally expect us to be on
time there but we have enough time for
our dialogue and I go with the first
round the round of coordinators or
representative of the political groups
the first intervention Mr Cristiano Epp
coordinator
thank you champ Madame commissioner Mr
Bureau I mean we had been thoroughly
reading what the EA had been publishing
and my first question is from both sides
um do you Mr Bureau have the impression
that the commission takes and the member
states take the right measures
and the same question goes to the
commissioner is the commission but also
what is the impression by the commission
are the member states taking the right
measure to consider that Gap
second question you have commissioner
had heard what Mr Bureau saying on
competitiveness
we are discussing now on
proposal from the commission on
clean hydrogen
there is nothing mentioned about
comparative costs
so have you any idea what are the
comparative costs of producing clean
hydrogen related to your proposal given
that in terms of the IRA an investor has
a precise idea of what is are this
energy costs because the Americans
addressing the cup X
and they have a precise idea about the
cost of hydrogen so where do you see
your proposal because it's described by
the industry in seikos as
overcomplicated over descriptive and we
did to much higher comparable cost than
clean energy clean hydrogen produced in
the s
and my last question is a little bit to
the market interventions and the dreams
here
I mean we should be grateful that the
commission like a crap was going
sideward when asked to intervene gas
market prices because it was an
um let's say the way the council wanted
to solve their own problems internally
by handing that over to the commission
but let's have a look I mean what in
effect happened is
um that the ECI that operates the gdf
mark in the Netherlands has start a
virtual trading point in London now in
case the gas price Gap is triggered so I
would like to ask you I mean how do you
see that I mean the effect of all that
polihu was simply that we are shifting
out the trading hubs out of Europe
so what do you expect in terms of
potential intervention into the electric
electricity Price Market
I think the first League proposals we
see that as fairly positive but I mean
in relation to what happened on that
intervention attitude of the gas market
what do you expect from the electricity
market and the results of an
intervention from the Commission in this
market thank you thank you thank you so
much
vice president of the committee on
behalf of snd
Commission
[Music]
um
industrial policies leadership
foreign
[Music]
Solutions
effort
[Music]
please
thank you chair and thanks to the
commissioner and to the director for
attending this meeting and discussing
these issues uh with us I have a
question regarding the uh balance
between the short term and the long-term
perspective on these issues because
let's remember why we are here we are
here because there was an opportunity
for Russia to use energy as a
geopolitical weapon and for us to be
vulnerable vulnerable because of it
because we are relying we are dependent
on fossil fuel and I think that the
image that the director showed on the uh
on the relative success that European
Union has had during 2022 why is this
because we invested a lot in Renewables
otherwise this had not been possible
and I am worried that many of the
proposals on the table right now will to
some extent reverse this and make it
more difficult this transition to more
inherently cheap sources of energy
enabling Renewables if we are using cfds
or if we are dividing the market into
several markets where fossil and nuclear
has a special price and are given some
extra support to be more
profitable
that can of course make some sense in
the very short term to alleviate price
but it also undermines the profitability
in investing in new Renewables
over the past few months I've met with
several stakeholders telling me that the
Merit systems of these proposals dampen
the will of investments in your
Renewables only yesterday I met with a
Renewables company that doesn't dare to
invest in Renewables because they not
know how profitable they will be because
they see these proposals on the table
that might undermine the investments in
the kind of energy that will keep us
independent for the future thank you
foreign
thank you I will speak in Polish
ed services
[Music]
opportunity
foreign
[Music]
the coordinator of the left
Mercy Mercy um
[Music]
the energy agency also raised into some
of the risks
listeners
decided to the exposure
entirely apart foreign
uh I'll kindly invite now first
commissioner Simpson and then uh
executive director uh b-roll to answer
to these questions but please do it in
five six minutes in order to have time
for the second round and then for the
answers and conclusions
dear Cadre please
I do my best to respect the time limit
but at the same time answer to all the
questions thank you for very uh
um good discussion and comments I will
start with Christian ehler and and the
issue of our competitiveness at high
prices first of all I do believe that
the temporary emergency measures that we
put in place helped us to achieve the
Target that we are facing right now that
price is for
coal oil even oil gas and electricity
are year on year bases um significantly
lower than they were last year and
um
if uh if that has some impact then it
doesn't mean that we can pick complacent
because we cannot continue pay hundreds
of billions of subsidies and this has
been possible also for our some
temporary measures that allowed member
states to reroute to the revenues to the
consumers but we need to continue
because diversification efforts and use
the joint purchasing to bring down the
gas prices and and of course this has
also uh effect on electricity prices and
third we need to ensure that um our
industry and also our smes are less
exposed to volatility of
high prices of the short-term
electricity marketing but that's why I
will propose in the electricity Market
design measures to facilitate access to
long-term instruments ppas and cfts
um
mainly for new Investments power
generation and this will help customers
benefit more directly from lower cost of
renewable generation but this also has
its impact to our industry our
green hydrogen sector
and and the last question about DDF
market and liquidity we just received
the report from asthma and they said
that clearly stated that there has not
been impact to liquidity in our gas gas
market only that allowed us to to move
further with extending this MCM towards
also to other hubs
um Miss Toya um I do agree that feeling
the storage by 95 last November
um it was a success but came at the cost
at a high cost and
um this is also one of the reasons why I
have organized a special meeting of the
gas security of Supply Group already in
February with all the stakeholders to
discuss best practices
um in feeling storage and new ways to
ensure that we achieve our Target this
year at a lower cost and based on this
input we are publishing soon a report on
the implementation of the storage
regulation with recommendations and best
practices and of course I'm happy to
discuss it with you
um and uh and there is also in parallel
and ongoing work to replace some of the
natural gases biomethane we created last
year industrial partnership biomethane
industrial partnership and as I I was
informing you the work is ongoing
um
Mr crudler the technology neutrality and
the role of nuclear
um
um well I am committed to respect
technological neutrality in our proposal
starting from the revision of the
electricity Market sign where this
principle will be reflected and from my
nij portfolio I want to bring two issues
on the focus first
security fuel supply for the nuclear
industry
because we still do have fine member
states who are dependent on Russian
nuclear Fuel and second promote the
competitiveness of the small modular
directors and the emergence of European
supply chain there and we are making
progress on the SMR partnership and and
I'm happy to keep you informed when the
dates will be agreed and but we can
already see that many member states are
taking steps to explore the deployment
of smrs and
um
and this is um also work supported by my
services
then
our challenge is short-term and long
term yes I do agree that that
um
Renewables and acceleration of
Renewables is not anymore only about our
climate
commitments it is part of security
supply policies and from the very
beginning this was our growth strategy
so last year we witnessed the record
volumes of new install capacity for
solar and wind and and actually
yesterday we had the solar power Summit
here in Brussels where my polish
colleague Minister mosquare was also one
of the keynote speakers because Poland
is not totally under under
um
um strong pressure to decarbonize but
they are doing excellently and and this
is visible both in uh in uh renewable
site but also in just transition regions
um and and of course right now member
states are in the process top grade the
national NHL climate plans I do hope
that that the common targets uh will
help us to
um to achieve
[Music]
um
higher targets than than seeing Possible
only a couple of years ago and and just
to wrap up
I do believe that our electricity Market
uh
um
so far single integrated electricity
Market brings major economic and energy
Security benefits across the EU but it
is also clear that during this energy
crisis we have seen some shortcomings
and now with this electricity Market
reform proposal next week
um we do our Optimus to bring the
benefits of low cost Renewables to all
the consumers thank you
thank you thank you so much Dr biron
please
and thank you very much also very brief
answers
he
industrial policy is to have the right
industry policy for the next chapter of
the Industrial Age
is in my view not only a task for the
the colleagues who are working on
industry at least there are four other
areas that it needs to be involved in
making the Europe's next industrial
master plan one is the Energy Group
energy policy
second is the trade for you see I think
it is time for Europe to show it is
trade masses
with the international partners
third is the foreign policy we have to
see with whom we are going to work in
terms of the Clean Energy Technologies
being alliances and being a much
stronger and fourth is of course it is
the uh the fiscal policies I think we
need a coordination of this four uh
groups working with the industry policy
now the last colleague in from the left
group mentions something which caused
most of the time unnoticed
renewable companies like any company
need to make in fact profits
and currently many renewable companies
in Europe are not making profits so the
whatever the regulation legislation we
have
should make them to turn them to
companies which make profits therefore
they can make a Investments an open
employment opportunities I think this is
something that we sometimes forget we
all know that the cost of rooms are
going down but this is not necessarily
equal that renewable companies are
making a profits
third point
a
nuclear
now
there are many countries in the world
when we look at it IA we look at not
only Europe the entire countries I can
tell you something very clearly
nuclear is making a comeback
around the world
Japan
imagine nuclear countries changing this
policy restarting its nuclear power
plants and thinking of the next wave of
nuclear Korea exactly the same changing
its policies and coming back to the
previous nuclear policies
go again from your Middle East India
China the United States influential
reduction acts provides incentives for
the lifetime exchange of nuclear power
plants existing ones and also for uh the
smrs and others Canada
and in Europe we all know that there are
different views
on nuclear but countries like from
Sweden to Netherlands Netherlands to
Poland France they all look at nuclear
very differently than they were looking
at a few years ago so uh therefore it is
not an exaggeration to say that nuclear
is making a comeback
now
of course every country makes its
decision by itself talking with their
people with the industry and take
decisions so but in my view if we talk
about the very effective many collection
this European domestic energy production
need to increase therefore Europe's
Reliance on the other countries should
decrease and this should be all done in
a carbon natural way I believe nuclei
can emerge as an important option
my last uh two points uh um Mr chairman
a
participate of a philosophical uh point
but some countries have mentioned we are
at such a crossroad in terms of energy
and climate challenges we have and they
both magnitude of the challenge
and the lack of time in my view
they mean that there is a bigger role
for public institutions
governments to play
vis-a-vis the markets of course we are
Market driven markets are the ones
Market Force are the one who makes the
decisions but if we are face such
immediate and strategic
challenges in front of our nose both
energy security and climate change we
should which could have geopolitical and
humanitarian consequences there is a
role a stronger role for public
institutions being in the driving seat
my last point
the past policies
I believe
this crisis is over when the dust
settles
it is a time it will be a time for
European countries at least some
European countries
to make a self-critic
of their a major strategic choice of
building an economic model
based on important energy big time from
one single country
this is a huge strategic mistake
and many of us are paying it
not only with electricity and gas bills
but much beyond that so therefore it is
of course for not for numb but when the
time comes we have to make this
discussion International Energy agency
will be following the discussion takes
place that that strategic decisions
being Reliant and fossil fuels of one
single country
one single company one trade route is
very risky and we have borne this years
and years and it will be the time that
we sit down and maybe discuss and make a
self-creating and and drive the lessons
from that thank you very much Mr
chairman
thank you thank you so much very true
I go now to the second round of
interventions interventions of one
minute please and I start of course with
President Erza buzek
uh thank you very much
dear Madam commissioner
and executive director it is always a
great pleasure to have you what is the
itra committee
a lot of information and great
discussion we survived as you said as
the European Union this winter and of
course our
guest storage generation was very very
helpful of course but now it's something
worrying because we are saying that
might be worse
next year
the the next year after after 2020 to
2025 show is going well since Wales why
why we feel that it could be worse we
don't have any energy Supply from Russia
and we are ready to stop it forever
so what is going worse probably because
we've got a very good
free Power EU proposal from European
commission correct
but we don't have enough legal framework
for that
biomethane 35 billion cubic meter in few
years
it would be as a legal
obligation 10 million tons of hydrogen
and all the priority corridors for
hydrogen should be a legal obligation
Madame commissioner it is just lying on
the table because in our
hydrogen gas package in Europe in
Parliament we've got everything written
in our regulation so we need your
support simply speaking
to agree with the member state that we
should have all such or of course heat
pumps should be also add to this
tremendous number of improvements
otherwise we will be worse and worse and
worse because we assume assume not more
not anymore
going back to Russia thank you so much
president okay thank you very much and
Mr director General thank you very much
for proposal of new uh uh well point of
view for our industrial strategy it's
very important thank you so much Mr
Gonzalez please
thank you for
it's going to allow us together
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much it was nice to meet
you both yesterday and it's also very
nice to welcome you to etra today both
to Miss Simpson and Mr birol
um many of the European countries that
have they are not so reliant on Russian
gas have one thing in common and that's
a factor I would like to bring up to the
table now and that's the bioenergy and
especially the case I think one of the
best examples is Lithuania thanks to the
production of bioenergy they were able
they were able to face out their
dependency on Russian gas long before
the war started and you miss the brawl
and the IAA presented the report in
March 2022 where you said that Europe
could double the energy production from
bioenergy and to in order to fast face
out the Russia natural gas despite so
the repower EU only mentions bioenergy
once hydrogen is mentioned over 50 times
so I would like to hear both Mr barole
how do you see that you European Union
is neglecting your advice on this not
bringing bioenergy into the the parcel
of Solutions in the repower EU and what
do you think the EU could do in terms of
enhancing and and utilizing the
potential of the bioenergy policies and
to the commissioner Madam Simpson
how do you see the red discussions on
bioenergy actually risking doing the
opposite uh lowering in the potential of
using bioenergy as a part of the
solution also the court case on biogas
how we will make sure that the court
case on lowering the tax on biogas will
not hamper the deployment of biomethane
within the repower EU the court case was
only so much
please
to a suggestion of you which was not yet
discussed at all it's Energy Efficiency
because this is we are dealing with
intensively currently so um you made
quite some proposals also beside heat
pumps which is a problem what we heard
but I would like to hear your opinion
you know what has been done until now
what had has been reached also with the
view to this maybe more difficult summer
because we should talk about it and put
pressure and maybe have your advice on
what kind of support we need from
governments in this regard thanks
thank you so much Mrs paulus please
excellent thank you both for your
inspiring inputs and your clear words I
would like to briefly focus on two
points first we will enter into the
maybe last try log on the Energy
Efficiency directive this afternoon and
if the EU continues to neglect this
Energy Efficiency despite of the new
realities that Dr Beryl has just
outlined we will not be able to handle
not only the next winter but also the
years ahead let's not forget that Energy
Efficiency is the base load of the
energy transition and my question to you
commissioner is will you commit to
staying strong on the commission's
repower EU Targets this afternoon or
this night second the global methane
tracker of the Ia produces a number of
roughly 5 million tons of methane being
emitted in the energy sector of the
European Union but taking a look over
our borders it's at least triple that
amount in the Mena region alone so Dr
Beryl how would you judge the effect of
including Imports in the EU legislation
on limiting methane emissions in the
energy sector would that alleviate our
situation and apologies I have to leave
because I have to fulfill my duty as
coordinator in the special Kobe
committee but I will watch the recording
for your answers thanks a lot thank you
so much Mrs
I'll be speaking in Bulgarian
I have exposure uh
um
foreign
thank you and thanks to commissioner and
the director for for interesting
messages and presentations
so some questions of one if China is
growing again
is there a likelihood that rather than
competing against ourselves and others
On the Border Market
that they will look to Russia to give
them the growing need they have for
energy
I will be hosting later on today
uh an event on that electricity Market
design reform on behalf of your electric
and that of course will have to direct
investment into Renewables as well as
storage Technologies and demand side
flexibility but also I'm interested to
ask the commissioner
where does she see the United Kingdom
fitting into our situation now that
we've agreed hopefully on the winter
framework and back in good terms again
especially in relation to cross-border
electricity trading and the single
electricity Market in Ireland
and the final question how will the new
legislation Aid multi-purpose
interconnectors which are so badly
needed thank you very much
thank you so much Mr Patterson please
Vice chair of our committee renew thank
you thank you chair and thank you
commissioner and and and thank you
director I think cattle you point out
too so the bacon and great successes so
far I was especially happy to hear you
your ambition of prolonging the 15
obligation or savings application at
least I think that is exactly the right
tool one of the many right tools to
apply in this situation in order to
ensure that we get through next window
as well so thanks for for this now now
Dr uh all I can assure you have many uh
readers in this room of of your great
Publications and and congratulations uh
we we really applaud it now I also
wanted to touch upon the Energy
Efficiency issue because uh you didn't
uh point to this in in your great slides
two questions basically uh are we doing
enough on on Energy Efficiency I mean I
know the answer is no obviously not but
but could you elaborate a little on this
and what what kind of suggestions uh iea
might have to us on on this secondly on
the Renewables
to consider this in the big picture uh
related to energy security is is
absolutely right and and and and and on
this point as well are we doing things
fast enough I know the easy answer again
here is is no you're pointing out to 41
additions of solar and wind in your
slide but clearly if we are to meet our
targets we have to ramp up much faster
than what we're capable of doing so
please uh a couple of words from this as
well thank you so much and congrats with
all your great work we we appreciate it
thanks thank you so much Mr Guyer please
electricity
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much and thank you for
being with us this morning uh Dr pirol
it's very appreciated how precise you
are in your recommendations
now I have a question regarding
digitalization in October 2022 the
commission adopted an energy action plan
that aims to support development of
sustainable cyber secure and competitive
market for digital Energy Services now I
will not ask you if you think that was a
timely Act
it entails the creation of a common
European energy data Space by 2024 it's
about coordination at EU level and also
it points out that investments in
digitalization is very key now
considering the need and the importance
of digitalization in the energy sector
to ensure that there are more Renewables
in the grid and to improve grid
flexibility and reliability despite the
intermittent nature of Renewables what
should be
the most important aspects or policy
measures that we as policy makers should
focus on what are the one two most
important points for us to act upon
regarding digitalization and energy when
we leave this very very important
meeting
thank you thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you chair and thank you
commissioner Simpson and Mr Burrell
I want to talk about the money
and I particularly want to talk about
Energy Efficiency uh Deputy Hildegard uh
Deputy Peterson both talked about Energy
Efficiency
which always seems to be the bridesmaid
but never the bride it seems to be
overlooked uh what can we do about this
as the reporter on the recast energy
performance of buildings directive I'm
delighted to see the strong interest in
buildings which consume 40 percent of
energy if we tackle buildings we're well
on our way to reducing energy use and
indeed uh tackling our climate goals
um but how can we step up the finance at
a European level we're talking about a
hydrogen bank which is great and yes we
need that but we also need the money for
renovations and thankfully the European
Investment Bank is strongly rebranding
as the climate Bank the European Central
Bank has came out in strong support for
an energy performance of buildings
directive but can we do more about
releasing the money for renovations and
in doing so ensure that Energy
Efficiency makes center stage thank you
thank you thank you so much Mr barenson
please
EPP
thank you very much as the roperator of
the European Parliament Zone the
industry strategy I completely
share the call of Mr b-roll uh on what
is needed for industry and for our
competitiveness competitiveness
competitiveness has been an issue raised
by the Epp uh continuously over the last
years and indeed the energy price is is
one of the main aspects for our industry
to be competitive in the coming years as
well and therefore I I really hope that
that next week and in the coming weeks
when the proposals of the commission are
presented that we somehow see something
of also a a 10e on steroids because I
think we need cross-border projects
cross-border infrastructure to tackle
the energy energy transition and the
energy prices together in in Europe and
I have a very concrete question to Mr
b-roll in your report of the
ee iea
of December you mentioned that the eu's
potential gas supply demand Gap could
reach 27 billion cubic meters in 2023
and I'm wondering where we are now thank
you
thank you so much Mr Heisel please
yeah thank you thank you chair uh the
commissioner I I would like to ask you
you know uh we really managed to secure
enough of energy sources for this winter
but uh because we were held also by the
weather as it was set also by the
absence of the China on the LNG market
and it's also positive that Europe uh
will end with uh relatively large stocks
this winter it's okay yeah but do you
expect that the storage is uh will be
filled to the level about the United
person also by this November without
major problems I mean taking account it
also uh for the last year we feel the
storage also by the Russian gas my
second question is one of uh be possible
this is really not popular because we
are dealing with a green deal is uh to
increase our resilience of the EU in
case of the oil and gas supplies is rely
on our own reserves it means exploration
and eventual extraction yeah of of the
deposits that we have in Europe what is
your view on this for example an account
the Netherland and what was happening in
Netherlands and do you see it also has
an opportunity to strengthen energy
security because despite the obvious
trends of the decarbonation we will need
these fuels for I don't know maybe 10
years at least thanks
thank you thank you very much Mr Hazel
uh Mrs Cornelius the greens
Simpson on
um
[Music]
please
thank you ciao I switched to Italian
um
Next Generation
Mrs piraki please it's your turn
thank you thank you chair and thank you
commissioner and Dr viral for being here
with us and it is important to have the
details from the host mouth but I would
like to stick on the on the early
warning coming from Mr viral
particularly not only on the on the
issue that the next winter will be much
more difficult than the current one but
also on the issue that it is where we
have to look for for solutions that they
are combining the the addressing of the
challenges of climate change and also
the energy security issues in this
regard I would like to focus on this
with the of the green hydrogen and
variation developments we have here in
the EU concerning the legislation Madame
commissioner my question is this a lot
of concerns are coming from from the
industry uh regarding the the due
delegated taxes that are they are
drafted and are in place uh this period
I would like to ask you if we are going
to proceed with clarifications in order
to to address the concerns coming from
the industry at the same time it is also
important to ask Mr Bill if he has some
kind of specific suggestions in order to
have a fast track development deployment
of hydrogen of green hydrogen
deployments in order to to increase the
security of supply thank you so much Mr
foxlank our reporter for Energy
Efficiency
thank you chair thank you
um Mrs Simpson and Mr pyrol for your
analysis
I am the rapper of the Energy Efficiency
directive which will we we will be
negotiating later today with the
commissioner and the council and we are
struggling here in the European
Parliament to keep a high level of
ambition we know that from the analysis
of the commission that one-third of the
natural gas savings from the fit for 55
package will have to come from the NFD
efficiency directive and that is why we
want a high Target and we think that the
repower EU proportional from the
commission is a good one so I'd like to
ask uh fatsi Mr Fatz on how you see the
role for Energy Efficiency in the
analysis that you presented to begin
with if we are to meet these challenges
of which you speak
how how important will Energy Efficiency
be and what will your advice to us be in
relation to this area Energy Efficiency
thank you
thank you so much last intervention Mr
Bloss please
I think he needed to live
then uh many many questions also
suggestions
I kindly invite you now to answer to to
this and then of course Mr birol
please commissioner Simpson
thank you and I'm very much enjoyed our
open exchange Fields today
um as you know Parliament has invited me
to be in front of plenary next Tuesday
um on on topic how we can ensure
Security in the EU energy security and
the EU this year so I will
um try to be very brief so that Dr
Verona will have more time because we
will enjoy an hour on Tuesday but I will
start with Dr Professor buzak's question
why we are worried about this winter
this is very simple Russia still
delivered 60 billion cubic meters of gas
via pipeline last year to Europe and the
rest that they didn't deliver anymore
they were not able to sell to
Alternative markets because they don't
have alternative pipeline Network that
means that was lost to Global markets
and as I mentioned there is 60 more to
lose we were able to replace partially
this this LNG but LNG Market this year
will be significantly more competitive
because due to the demand from Asia so
we know that we have to replace the
remaining gas with Renewables and we
have to prioritize savings so I
um I assure you NH efficiency is a top
priority of ours without savings without
prolonging also our temporary measures
to cut gas consumption but also to
prioritize these efforts that member
states made to cut electricity Peak our
consumption we will be in difficult more
difficult situation and that of course
means that that you can expect that we
will address all the remaining
bottlenecks so not any more permitting
that we have addressed but we have lack
of skilled Workforce Supply change for
some renewable sectors are too
and and of course creates well you can
shorten the permitting but if our trees
are not able to connect all those
installations so we are missing the
Target and and as I mentioned these some
of these we will address next week in
our Net Zero industrial Act
and um and from my side in the longer
perspective this year I want to propose
also industrial partnership to work on
skills and to push the new Eco design
and then actually labeling of cooling
and heating appliances so that we can
replace in building sector fossil fuels
with heat pumps and and then of course
we are very dependent on our trusted
Partners there was a question about our
cooperation with UK you have praised a
lot our partners from Norway and
Azerbaijan and Algeria and United States
but of course UK is also like-minded
partner who accelerates offshore wind
and has delivered some very necessary
gas in previous year and I hope that our
cooperation is now on steady base thank
you see you tomorrow not tomorrow this
evening and next week
thank you thank you so much commissioner
Please Mr Bill please thank you Mr
chairman so Mr chairman first of all I
think it is the last round we are
talking I it's the first time I came to
this Committee in person I can't tell
that I am very impressed with the
questions and the very surprised with
the fact that many of you read our
reports I am really honored for that and
I will tell my colleagues when I go back
to Paris and in response chairman may I
offer the members of this Parliament
when they were to come to Paris I have a
wonderful office with the Eiffel Tower
View and very nice coffee machine to
invite you to come to my office and have
a discussion on these issues more in
that and thank you very much for your
interest once again invitation accepted
and thank you for this thank you but
please one by one so not only at the
same time so I have a small office
thank you very much much appreciate it
Mr chairman uh first of all uh Mr buzek
said why don't we stop completely uh
next year or we have to think of 2017
2019 2030 that the Reliance on the
Russian gas or other countries yes now
the energy sector is a very particular
sector it is not like the I.T sector if
you don't like your iPhone you can
change it immediately
but energy sector is bound with a huge
infrastructure and a consuming
equipments it is like a not like a
bicycle like it's like a big tanker and
you changed the route very very slowly
unfortunately therefore as I start to
say we made a huge mistake
in Europe by having a over-reliance on
one countries fossil fuel exports
it is in my view we said several times
to those countries to put all the bags
in one basket was a strategic mistake
and in my view I am an energy person not
an energy mistake but as a foreign
policy mistake and a geopolitical uh
mistake so therefore it will take some
time we are going in the right direction
we can definitely accelerate this
and a we can definitely learn from this
lesson and the steps we take should be a
based on these lessons one of them is
the questions one of the colleagues
asked from which countries we can get a
new gas Imports
now there's a lot of discussion we know
all the countries how much each country
ever gas reserves how much they can
export and what does it cost
but I think as Europe we have to be very
careful
because we have a energy security
problem now but we have another
challenge which is the climate change we
shouldn't forget and we should be proud
that the Europe was the champion years
and years of fighting against climate
change we shouldn't leave it to the
other countries so therefore when I look
at the numbers before the invasion
European gas consumption was in a
decline already
it was declining
now the The Gas We are going to find
should be in the one that will replace
the Russian gas we would need and in
that respect since the European economy
should not be relying disproportionately
on gas the gas contacts we are going to
make country X Y or Z
I hope it to be diverse should be as
much as possible
short-term contracts
and the projects we are making to import
that cash transported cash should be
designed in a way that that can be
repurposed to use hydrogen in the future
so these are the two things that I would
like to bring to attention right
countries
flexible and not long-term contracts as
much as possible and also designed the
infrastructure accordingly that they can
be repurposed
amen one other issue I am so happy to
hear the medical expansion Energy
Efficiency
in Europe
every country has an energy potential
some countries have oil some have gas
some have huge in the universe some have
called some have hydropower
but all the countries have won energy
source potential which is Energy
Efficiency
and in Europe we got it we did a good
job up to now but there is a huge
potential to improve it which means that
is put very eloquently it is a base lot
of our Energy System
how do we do it there are two ways
one providing incentive for the
consumers to do it
in terms of consumers what kind of
incentives more financial incentives
in terms of buildings for example one of
the colleagues mentioned the buildings
today in Europe we are we have a very
old building stock
and we are renovating only one percent
of our buildings each year to be in line
with our climate Targets in Europe fit
455 it should be three times higher
renovation in the buildings
so one area is providing instantly for
uh efficiency and the other one is in
line with what I said in the previous
round the public sector being in the
driving seat a bit more in than in the
past regulations standards and Norms
they should be stricter and sticker in
my view and there are long-term
standards Norms of regulations and as
Madam commissioner said for the next
year having the 15 percent Claus is a
good one
methane so when we talk about climate
change we talk all the time on carbon
dioxide emissions
but there is other one which is a bit
more uh under the shadow of CO2 carbon
dioxide but it is even more dangerous
because in the short term it is creating
a lot of problem for us
and but the good news is
reducing methane emissions is much
easier and much less costly
75 percent of the global methane
emissions in the world today can be
minimized and nullified at no cost at no
cost if you take the right measures
because it is basically fixing the pipes
that they don't methane doesn't like gas
doesn't leak I just make it too extreme
but just to make sure that you don't
need a big technology you don't need to
discover anything you just need to the
the oil Angus industry not to be greedy
but to make the investments in order to
make the necessary take the necessary
steps so therefore it is the eu's
position in terms of
the gas Imports putting the methane
emission is an important uh item is in
my very good and in my view there may be
even a room for making them even a
sicker so methane please let's keep an
eye on that
say again take a question uh what can we
do more in Renewables
we can do many things but if I can if I
if you give me the right to ask for one
thing only
you know why we had a big increase in
last a year
because of the following many countries
were in a problem how can we bring
energy so therefore they did something
that they didn't do long times they have
cut the permitting Allah since in time
so this is the it creates a lot of lot
of problem that a lot of projects are in
the bureaucratic phases of getting the
the licensing from a permitting from the
authorities governments need to do one
small thing
increase the workforce in the permitting
licensing bureau's offices and make it
much more nimble
so this is the if you ask me one thing I
am a
pragmatic man this is the when I look at
we could talk with the companies
um of course every company when I took
the business they always attacks
instantly this Sunday but the main issue
is today the fault line is permitting
and license and takes a lot of time in
Europe please please please shorten it
as much as possible if it is one thing I
would like to mention a bit two last
points Mr chairman I know that you want
me to finish but generally yes two two
last points
in my view bio energy is the blanched
spot of the the European energy debate
in general with the ngos with everything
together we have a lot of potential
there in terms of bioenergy if we play
our cards uh well we can make a
significant amount of uh contribution I
have to just say it and stop it here
especially in some countries it can make
a substantial contribution if you play
our cards right
a last two points I'm sorry one in the
grits and digitalization other one is uh
on hydrogen now
dear colleagues just let me tell you one
thing very helicopter View
we have oil gas Renewables this and that
hydrogen but when I look at the global
energy pictures where it came and
talking with the investors companies
where it will go governments I can't
tell you something very simple
the future is electric
the global Energy System will be more
and more electric it is under
transportation how we our Mobility
system how we at home how we use energy
for heating for for everything our
industry sector the trenches and the
electricity site electricity will be
very important for in our lives less
fossil fuels oil gas called less
molecules and more electricity now here
what is important we all want to see new
power plants solar and wind some of us
nuclear some of this but
the veins if you think of the body human
body the veins the is the Greece
have strong how well designed how modern
and how flexible our grits are
and what makes our grits more smart much
efficient and much better in terms of
the electricity movement is the
digitalization
so the right digital policy merit with
the right clean energy policy is the the
formula for the success for Europe and
as well
for hydrogen
a
in fact when you look at Europe there is
one lesson we have to learn and I have
to imagine this Mr chairman we all talk
about solar energy and I show you a
chart that today China produces about 90
percent of solar panels in the world but
20 years ago the picture was very
different
it was Germany it was Spain it was Italy
started the in the Solar put a lot of
subsidies but after a few years they
dropped the ball and China continued and
today Chinese leader a cleared energy
technology is lacking running a marathon
okay it's 42 kilometers Europe run the
marathon first 10 kilometers in the
front
but then slow down get tired thought of
something else and China came and left
past Europe and became number one nobody
nobody gives a gold medal a in the
marathon who finishes the 10 kilometers
as the first
if you want to get the gold medal you
have to finish the 42 kilometers first
which means the policies
the right policy is put in place and
giving a confidence to the investors
and it is the reason I am saying that
for the hydrogen for the electrolyzers
we have to give a visibility to the
investors
Financial visibility
this is the only thing I would like to
say in terms of hydrogen but we should
be evaded today in terms of cost
competitiveness Europe is not
the very best place we have to improve
that and second maybe last warning
please please
hydrogen
not today and even not tomorrow will be
soul of our problems maybe the day after
tomorrow so please do not expect that
the hydrogen will uh we solve all of our
problems from one day other it will grow
it will with the increasing demand of
giving them incentives but to have a
fixation that the hydrogen will solve
our problems in the short or even a
medium term would be taking our
attention from the solutions that we
have under our hands now and to lose
some perhaps time and attention just
wanted a friendly uh warning here Mr
chairman I'll stop here thank you thank
you so much it was really a very
interesting meeting a privilege to have
commissioner caddy Simpson executive
director Bureau together with us today
with this I formally closed the meeting
see you next time thank you very much
colleagues we run to the press
conference
thank you